hello and welcome to the daily climate
show coming up
with much of europe in a severe heatwave
we report from portugal which is on a
high state of alert for wildfires
irreversible biodiversity damage could
kill off mankind a dire warning from the
environment agency chief but there is
hope
and how barbie is turning dr jane
goodall to a life in plastic ahead of
world chimpanzee day
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to our world hear from those
hit hardest by those changes and report
on the race for solutions
so to start portugal is bracing itself
for record temperatures this week with
the mercury set to hit 46 or even 47
degrees in some regions the country is
now at the third highest of four alert
levels with the public banned from
accessing forests deemed to be at risk
there have been hundreds of wildfires in
recent days with thousands of
firefighters tackling the blazes but
forecasters are warning that the worst
is yet to come
much of europe is caught in a severe
heat wave temperatures in some parts of
france are expected to reach 39 degrees
this week heightening concerns they
could trigger further wildfires
the italian government has declared a
state of emergency in five northern
regions due to drought with crops
failing and the country's longest river
drying up parts of spain are expected to
reach 42 degrees this week in some areas
along the border with portugal
and in portugal itself the wildfires
have left at least 29 people injured as
thousands of firefighters and dozens of
aircraft there battle those blazes while
temperatures are forecast to reach
upwards of 45 degrees
from there our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter sent
this report
we're in an area north of lisbon where a
wildfire blazed through this area one of
the worst actually thousands of
firefighters battling hundreds of blazes
in extreme temperatures things are under
control relatively speaking for now but
let me show you why it's a problem
people live in these areas communities
have been fighting the fires away from
their homes and hoping that it doesn't
destroy
all they own this isn't just an issue
here in portugal it's an issue across
europe and climate change say scientists
is helping to drive the conditions that
make all of this worse increasingly
frequent increasingly severe heat events
and drought events combining in a toxic
combination really to extend fire
seasons and misery for millions of
people
now
the forecast is for more extreme
temperatures in the coming days heading
up to perhaps 46 degrees in this part of
europe but spain and france and of
course the uk going to be feeling those
temperatures later in the week too
climate change correspondent hannah
thomas peter there reporting from
portugal let's get some more climate
news now nearly 100 billion pieces of
plastic are thrown away each year by uk
households the greenpeace survey also
found just 12 percent of all plastic
waste is likely to be recycled in the uk
and more than 80 percent of it comes
from food and drink packaging it
highlights that plastic bottles and cups
can take
450 years to break down while releasing
chemicals into the soil
the uk installed the lowest number of
heat pumps in europe last year less than
43 000 were installed in 2021 according
to the european heat pump association
this falls far short of the target set
by the government to install 600 000
every year by 2028.
installing pumps reduces carbon
emissions produced through heating homes
by drawing heat from the air or the
ground
germany's vice chancellor and climate
minister says keeping the country's
remaining nuclear power reactors running
will do little to address the problems
caused by a potential shortfall in gas
supply robert habeck's comments come as
europe continues to struggle with an
energy crisis following a fall in supply
of russian gas damaging the continent's
energy security germany and the
netherlands have previously said they'll
reactivate coal power plants to make up
for the shortfall
now humanity is closer than ever to
irreversible biodiversity damage which
could kill humans that's the warning
from the environment agency chief today
in a dire speech to mark a report which
reveals the extent of biodiversity loss
across the uk sir james bevin explained
that people not just plants and animals
are at risk if we don't take better care
of the natural world
now you could say uh does this matter
does it really matter if the vole
goes the way of the dodo
well yes it does matter it matters
immensely because the biodiversity
crisis and let's be clear that's what it
is
it won't just kill the plants and the
animals it's killing it will kill us as
well
that's because nature provides us with a
host of things that we depend on
well the speech wasn't all doom and
gloom though so james did make it clear
that it's not too late to turn things
around if natural habitats are restored
well joining me now to talk more about
this is sarah fowler chief executive of
the wildfowl and wetlands trust who've
been working with the environment agency
on this sarah thank you so much for
joining us so could you explain a bit
about why we're losing so much
biodiversity and also what sort of life
forms are being particularly affected
so so nature is beautiful essential but
it is threatened
for us here at the wild final weapons
trust we're particularly concerned about
the alarming loss that we've seen in
wetland habitat and wetland species
we've lost almost 7 90
of wetlands globally since in the last
100 years
across across the nation in the world
now our wetlands are incredibly
important they're the lifeblood of the
planet and they're important service
stations for birds breeding birds um
like the curly like the blacktail godwit
and we're starting to see losses of
those and we're doing a lot of work
there but they're also really important
for natural toads damselflies those
beautiful species that you see and we're
seeing that across the across the piece
not just in fresh water but also in our
terrestrial habitat like trees and
woodlands
as well as being lost massively
and the study shows that 15 of flora and
fauna are at serious risk of extinction
what would happen if that 15 did become
extinct
the scary thing is we've lost species
already as a nation and as a globe
and these species are really important
now indicators for the health of the
habitat so as we start losing species
it's telling us a really important
signal that actually our habitat is in a
massive decline when our habitat that
the species live on is in a decline
we're losing the essential services that
the habitat provides
so wetlands are incredible carbon stores
they store carbon and prevent it going
into the atmosphere they're incredibly
good at helping us buffer against
extreme weather events we know about the
hot weather at the moment wetlands and
cities are incredibly cooling the
environment they're really good at
buffering us against us flood risks as
we lose species we lose those services
basically that our natural habitats
provide to us so it has a real personal
impact on us and our cities and then
every different individual in the nation
and are we losing these wetlands to
housing and industry and things like
that
if that's the case what needs to change
we need to stop building houses on on
wetlands
so we there's a range of reasons why
we're losing habitats we built on them
for wetlands we've drained them and
we're polluting them all of those things
have a massive impact on the habitats
and the resilience of our habitats what
we need to do is protect and protect
what we've already got let's keep hold
and not lose any more biodiversity or
any more wetland habitats or habitats at
all and then we need to restore and
create and that's where there's a huge
hope for us as a nation and as a planet
that if we start looking at solutions
that build in wetlands and build in
nature back into infrastructure we can
start building that natural service that
our habitats and nature provide to us we
can start building in flood defence
schemes that are natural flood defense
schemes we can start building in natural
ways of storing carbon in our salt
marshes
but just one really simple example for
you we've been working with the
environment agency to on a major coastal
realignment project in the seven estuary
called stiet
that was created in 2011
it's managed by ourselves at wwt it's a
much cheaper and sustainable solution
for protecting homes from flooding but
it also actually stores 18 000 tons of
carbon in the four years since it's been
working actively as a wetland habitat
and to put that into context that hope
that amount of carbon stored is as much
as if you planted one million trees and
have grown them for 10 years nature can
provide a brilliant solution to some of
the challenges we've got with climate
that's so brilliant to hear so just
quickly do you think enough is being
done to restore these habitats or do you
think the government perhaps needs to
invest more money
i i i'd like us to build a future
revolution that's both green and blue a
future revolution for infrastructure
building that builds in nature
designs in right from the start
i think more can be done on that
and we at wwt and other environmental
ngos stand ready to help that happen
wetlands and nature can be our solution
to the biodiversity crisis climate
triceps crisis and also the well-being
crisis as well
sarah fowler chief executive of the
wildfowl and wetlands trust thank you
very much for joining us today
now just before we leave you barbie have
announced a doll modelled on the
celebrated conservationist dr jane
goodall ahead of world chimpanzee day
the environmentalist is well known for
her work in protecting the primates from
extinction and she's hoping that the
dolls will encourage youngsters to study
nature
when i heard that
jane bobby doll was going to be made i
was really happy because actually i'd
been suggesting it for a long time that
girls don't want just to be film stars
and things like that but many of them
like me want to be out in nature
studying animals and so a barbie doll
whose jane is a super idea
and as you saw that doll comes with a
pair of binoculars and a notebook and a
chimpanzee definitely one for the
christmas lists now just before we go if
you've got any questions about the
climate issues in the show or literally
anything about climate change do send us
what's puzzling you and we'll do our
best to give you an answer on our
weekend climate show hosted by the
environment broadcaster and author tom
heap if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can send us those
questions directly that is all from us
today thanks so much for watching we'll
see you next time bye